Shake It Off
[Applause]
lizzo's latest Bop is ripped straight
from the headlines
yeah it's Ariana dubose's rap that's
been heard around the world
there will be dancing there will be
singing there was plenty of that at the
baftas on Sunday
[Music]
Ariana opened the British Academy film
Awards the UK's version of the Oscars
with a medley of sisters are doing it
for themselves We are family and an
original rap which shouted out all the
female nominees
awesome ladies in the room supporting
and leading all here I presume yeah the
West Side Story actresses bit got some
very confused looks Michelle I've loved
you from the stars
the performance inspired in onslaught of
memes critics
Shake It Off
and now a loving parody from lizzo
during a recent concert
[Applause]
yeah seems like lizzo thought the wrap
was good as hell so good she worked it
into her live show
[Applause]
I'm floating all over the place for
Ariana the mixed reviews sent a clear
message that it was time for a break
from Twitter so she deactivated her
account
according to a bafta producer Ariana was
invested in the number not only did she
co-write it Michelle I loved your own
star but she also rehearsed it while
getting her makeup done Broadway music
director Benjamin rauhala shared the
moment on tick tock
is my woman King Ariana has yet to
return to Twitter but Benjamin wants us
to know she's been giggling at everyone
who has the campy little number stuck in
their head I'm just really proud of what
we made also in Ariana's Corner one of
the event's producers Nick bullin who
called the backlash incredibly unfair
pointing out that it was a great year
for women in film and they wanted to
celebrate that look at you you're just
literally the embodiment of like female
empowerment thank you I appreciate it I
mean that's what we got to do out here
as for memes there's been plenty like
this one shared by pop culture
commentator Evan Ross Katz
Ariana not only saw it she loved it
sliding into the comments to give it her
approval
[Music]
she also shared this clip of the New
York City gay men's chorus putting their
own spin on her song writing yes Gents
[Music]
so I'm trying to stay awake and present
for each and every one of these very
special moments of course it's no
surprise Ariana's having fun with her
viral moment
and not everyone can say they got
karaoke'd by lizzo
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign